مجموعه من التطورات والقرارات من ماسك في
تويتر الايام الماضيه متصدره للعناوين
كلام عن حسابات محظوره او الحسابات
المحظوره وكشف المزيد من فضائح الاداره
السابقه وفسادها كمان كلام كثير عن حساب
ترامب وحضره ومن اقل من 24 ساعه في تطور
جديد
ومنتظر فاتر تويتر اعلن واخيرا عن اعاده
اطلاق خدمه تويتر بلو وهي الخدمه اللي راح
تكون باشتراك شهري واللي من ضمن
المميزاتها توفيق الحساب وميزات اخرى
عديده واللي من لما ماسك اعلن عنها وهي
عامله نوع من انواع الاشكالات هذه الخدمه
مقابل الثمانيه دولارات شهريا كانت من وقت
ما اعلن عنها ماسك عامله جدله كبير
ومشاهير كثير حتى اعلن تركن منصه او قالوا
انها ما انهم ما راح يدفعوا حتى لو خسروا
توفيق الحساب عموما اعلان تويتر الجديد
قال انه الخدمه خلاص راح تطرح غدا الاثنين
ومن ضمن ميزاتها توفيق بعد ان تتم مراجعه
الحساب وتعديل التغريدات وتحميل
الفيديوهات بجوده عاليه جدا وغيرها واعلنت
الشركه كمان انها قريبا جدا رح يكون
حسابات الشركات راح تكون بالفعل رمز
التوفيق لالها باللون الذهبي والحكومات
راح تكون بالرمادي كل نهايه تفاصيل
سمعناها من قبل في تسريبات وتقارير ومكانت
مفاجاه الحقيقه لكن المفاجاه الكبرى كانت
بالاشتراك الشهري تويتر اعلن انه الاشتراك
راح يكون ثمانيه دولارات شهريا واللي
باشترك عن طريق الويب هذا طبعا عن طريق
الويب اما اللي راح يشترك عن طريق اي او
اس يعني عن طريق اجهزه ايفون او ايفون هذا
راح يدفع 13$ في الشهر يعني من الاخر ماسك
بيقول لمستخدمين ابل راح تدفعوا اكثر
ليه بنقول انه الموضوع مفاجاه لانه اولا
ما سمعنا ولا حتى تسريبات عن الموضوع من
قبل هيك وثانيا لانه ماسك المفروض خلاص
صلح الامور ما اقل لو متذكرين من اسبوعين
تقريبا ماسك فجه في سلسله تغريدات شن حرب
طاحنه على ابل وحكى عن نيه الشركه حجم
تويتر من متجررها وعمل استفتاء للناس عن
ابل وزبائنها وعمل كمان منشن للرئيس قابل
حتى وقال انه الشركه وقفت اعلاناتها على
تويتر وتكلم كمان وهجمهم وقال انهم
بيفردوا ما سماه ضريبه سريه 30% على كل
شيء على مجرهم ومش بس هيك بس حتى وصلت في
انه يؤكد انه مستعد يصنع هاتف ينافس في
ايفون لو الطريه يعمل هيك لكن بعدها بكم
يوم على طول الماسك نشر فيديو من داخل مقر
شركه ابل وقال انه التقى
نصا انه كان في محادثات جيده بيني وبين
بنتكم وانهم حلوا سوء تفاهم اللي صاير
وقتل اكدت انها ابدا ما فكرت بحضرتك تطبيق
من متجررها وناس افترضت انه خلص الامور
تمام وتصلحت لكن مع اعلان اليوم رجعت
الكثير من الاسئله هل معنى الرسوم لزياده
لمستخدمي ابل لانه الدنيا بين ماسك وابل
لسه متوتره والحرب نزلت قائمه راح نسال
هذا السؤال لضيفنا في رياض الخبير التقنيه
عبد العزيز الحمادي اهلا وسهلا فيك استاذ
عبد العزيز معنا في تفاعلكم نطرح حلقه نفس
السؤال هل معنى ذلك بانه الحرب ما زالت
قائمه وما تصلح اي شيء ما بين لهم ماسكو
تيم كوك لما تقابلوا
طبعا اتخيل انه اليوم لمسك يعني وقت زياره
لشركه ابل حاول بطريقه باخرى فعليا
استثناء 30 بالمئه الخاصه بي يعني
اشتراكات تويتر بلو اللي يدفع المستخدمين
ولكن من طبيعه الحال عاقل تعتبر
الاشتراكات حق حصري واساسي لها لن تتنازل
عنه لانه ما تنازلت قبل مع تطبيقات شهيره
مثل النتفليكس نت فليكس واجهت نفس التحدي
مع شركه ابل عده سنوات 30% اللي كان
ياخذها شركه ابل من مشتركين نتفليكس اللي
يشتركون عن طريق الايفون همم واللي جعل
شركه نت فلكس انها تلقي الاشتراك والدفع
عن طريق التطبيق وتاهت الدفع فقط عن طريق
المنصه الالكترونيه عن طريق الويب بنفس
همم القيمه لم تتغير سياستها في النهائيه
فنفس القضيه حصلت مع شركه تويتر شركه ابل
لم تتنازل ولا اتوقع تتنازل عن 30% يعتبر
حصري ولكن في نهايه المطار شركه هاف ده من
تويتر بانها تمتلك او يعني على مجرها
الكتروني تطبيقي يعتبر من افضل التطبيقات
الشبكات التواصل الاجتماعي على مستوى
العالم وفي نهايه المطاف ايضا الى مصر لن
يستطيع في طريقه او باخرى انه يعني يترك
شركه همم ابل او ان يخسرها خاصه انه عدد
كبير جدا من المستخدمين في امريكا وفي
العالم العربي وفي غير من الدول يقوم
باستخدام تويوتا
همم يعني همم يطلب 13 دولار شهريا من
مستخدم وبتقول انه ابل ما راح تتنازل انا
ما اتنازلت قبل هيك عن النسبه النسبه
الارباح بالنسبه لها طب همم مين اللي راح
يعاني مستخدمي ابل في هذه الحاله راح
يضيعوا هل نقدر نقول انه راح يضيعوا ما
بين طمع تويتر او لهم ماسك
طبعا اليوم ماسكي يدير شركه تويتر كشركه
خاصه فيه يريد تحقيق عوائد ماليه تغطي
الخسائر الكبيره اللي يعني شرفها اثناء
شرائه لشركه تويتر فوق طريقه اخرى لا يريد
التنازل عن 8 دولار اللي بناء عليه وقام
بعمليه عمليات حسابيه كثيره من انه هي من
ستفقده من الخسائر الكبيره في يوم همم
وصلت الى ال ال شركه ابل وانه 30% ياخذون
فان تتكلم تقريبا عن قرابه الثلاثه حتى
اخذها شركه ابل من ثمانيه دولار خذ بالك
بزياده هذه الزياده لكن ماسك ذكي قام
بايتاحه انه انت في النهايه لكن خيار
كمستخدم تريد اشتراك عن طريقه تطبيق ادفع
هذا المبلغ
11$ ولكن اذا اردت الدفع ثمانيه دولار
بامكانك الخروج فقط من التطبيق وفتحه عن
طريق المتصفح بنفس الطريقه ستقوم فقط بدفع
ثمانيه دولار فتخيل انه اغلب
يعني بتعتقد
عبد العزيز ما بتعتقد بانه هذا راح يؤثر
على شعبيه تويتر لانه لما نحكى عن 8
دولارات قامت الدنيا وما قعدته في ناس
ومشاهير كثير قالوا انهم راح يغلقوا
حساباتهم ما بدهم يستعملوه تويتر اصلا همم
ما بتعتقد بانه 13 دولار بغض النظر حتى لو
في طريقه
لالتفاف عليها ما راح تعمل مشكله عند
المستخدمين
يعني تحدي بعض المستقيم والاستمرار في
تويتر ولكن على ال- همم يعني التجارب
السابقه اللي حصلت في نتفليكس وغيره من
الشبكات اللي اجبرت على دفع مبالغاليه
ورفعت الاسعار في البدايه كان في نزول لكن
في النهايه لا تسال الاعداد تزيد همم الى
ماسكه اعلم قبل الفتره انه عدد المستخدمين
الجدد الذي يسجلوا في تويتر 2 مليون
مستخدم جديد يوميا يعني احنا نتكلم تقريبا
في السنه الواحده بس اذا استمر على نفس
الاعداد 700 مليون مستخدم جديد يعني خلال
سنه اذا استمرت على نفس الاعداد سيصل عدد
المستخدمين الى قرابه مليار مستخدم همم في
شبكه تويتر من ذلك الاعداد لا تزال في
زياده على حسب الارقام اللي جالسين نشوفها
فلا يتخيل انه هذا سيسبب عائل يعني عائق
لانه الدفع هذا ليس مزايا اساسيه في تويتر
انما مزايا اضافيه همم
الرفع فيديوهات عاليه الدقه او ربما على
توثيق معينه اصبح هذه العلامه ليست بصراحه
ذات قيمه مستقبلا خاصه الى الواحد اصبح
مشتريها طيب عبد العزيز الحمادي الخبير
التقنيه لو سمحت ابقى معنا في لدينا موضوع
اعتقني اخر رح نتحدث فيه بعد قليل